this is the X9 Pro Robot vacuum sent to
us and sponsored by uvclean and is part
of a major robovac Revolution going on
right now that you're probably not
paying attention to and that Revolution
is happening in three parts technology
functionality and convenience the X9 Pro
excels at all three of these because
it's jam-packed with sophisticated
sensors to create a smart AI system
which I'll explain in this video and it
comes with convenient and clever
functionality that is a must-have for
robot vacuums and it's packed with
software and features that make it
incredibly convenient which is the main
reason anyone buys these things anyway
now when I was younger my mom always
told me that the only way to do a good
job mopping the floors was scrubbing
them on your hands and knees but the X9
Pro is actually able to mimic this with
its unique mopping system that comes
with dual pentagonally shaped mop pads
that are able to cover more ground and
overlap lap as they spin at 180 RPMs
which is about three times every second
but the biggest reason it does so well
is because the mod pads are actually
motorized so they push down on the floor
with up to 2.2 pounds of force while
mopping which means it actually scrubs
the floor as well instead of just wiping
them not only that but the X9 Pro does
what humans do when they mop it goes
back to the base station every few
minutes to literally wash and scrub the
mop pads against friction pads on the
inside of the base station to remove
dirt cleaning and saturating the pads
again so they're actually cleaning your
floors and not spreading dirt everywhere
it even lifts up the pads when it heads
back to the station to avoid secondary
pollution finding the shortest path to
save time and unlike other robot vacuums
you can choose how often it cleans the
pads within the app as well as how wet
you want them to be and the suction
strength as well I'm up to a powerful
5500 Pas but here is the best part of
all it doesn't just mop it actually
vacuums the floors and mops at the same
time as it moves around the spinning
brush in the front collects debris on
the floor and pushes it towards the
floating tangle-free brush roll to
vacuum it up and at the same time the
mops in the back are mopping so
everything gets done in one swoop
cleaning your whole floor in half the
time it'll even vacuum your carpets
without getting them wet by raising the
mop pads as high as an industry-leading
12 millimeters as soon as it detects
carpets using its AI sensors and then
instantly drops the pads back down to
the floor when it goes back on hard
floors so the X9 Pro truly does clean
your whole floor with whatever flooring
types you have due to all of the
functionality it packs into it and it
does it all without any user
Intervention which makes it super
convenient and speaking of convenience
the base station has two large 4.1 liter
tanks one for clean water and one for
dirty so you can have it clean your
floors multiple times without having to
fill up or empty them on top of that the
youth cleaned app works very well
showing you real-time info about the X9
Pro like the battery life the map of
your house and what it's currently doing
allowing you to pause or start cleaning
and customize a bunch of different
settings like suction power mop washing
frequency and auto drying duration yes
it uses 104 degree fahrenheit hot air to
dry the pads every time after it's done
mopping which ensures that mildew and
bacteria won't grow on the wet pads so
they won't smell it also comes with a
manual control feature so instead of
having to pick it up and take it to an
area that you want spot cleaned you can
literally control it like an RC car and
spot clean the area that needs cleaning
but my favorite convenience feature is
that you can schedule the X9 Pro to run
at any time on whatever basis you'd like
like every day at 11 30 PM when the kids
are asleep and yes it works just fine in
complete darkness due to its advanced
technology so let's talk about that the
X9 pro has AI map 3.0 technology which
enables multi-floor mapping in real time
even highlighting obstacles on the map
like couches or kitchen islands it does
this by using the iPath laser navigation
system with its 3D time-of-flight
sensors and inaccurate AI camera system
called AIC which allows it to see
obstacles in front of it and avoid them
in real time it also has a bunch of
other sensors like for recognizing
carpet and boosting suction or other
floor types and it comes with speakers
to let you know what it's doing voice
control with Alexa and Google assistant
and of course child lock so k kids don't
turn it on themselves so overall the X9
Pro is a very good robovac jam-packed
with technology and features and it's
only 8.99 being hundreds of dollars less
expensive than robovax with similar Tech
and quality and right now you can buy it
using the link and coupon code in the
description below to save a hundred and
eighty dollars for a limited time so
thanks for watching and let me know your
thoughts on the X9 Pro down in the
comment section below and thanks once
again for yuffieclean for sponsoring
this video